richard gore from university of
cambridge country
he will also talk about instrumental ink
let me say that i don't feel like i have
much else to say after ismael's
wonderful talk but i'll still try and uh
i guess i'll just
try to convey one message that chsh
inequalities and stuff like that
do show up when we consider uh project
identification in statistics and
econometrics and for that case
especially when that involves variables
we would want to use those inequalities
to get the tightest boundaries possible
for partial identification uh this is
joint work as part of my phd thesis done
with thomas richardson
okay so let's start with our usual graph
so for now just think about a really
ideal case where we have
z being completely randomized okay so
think about the encouragement design
uh and for this talk i will going to
assume that
the instrument the treatment and the
outcome why all of them are going to be
binary
uh and
here is the case uh for example uh when
you walk into a clinic and the doctor
secretly draws a
coin
from his drawer and just see you know
whether he or she wants to give you
encouragement to get vaccine
and that's the
instrument z a zero being encouraged uh
not encouraged one being encouraged
and x
is a treatment
with whether you do go to get the
vaccine and why is the outcome whether
you get infected or not
uh and i'm going to use the notation y
of xc to denote the counterfactual
outcome how do you you know take in
the specific encouragement status and
specific treatment
and the goal of this talk would be not
about the type of inequalities for
falsifying the instrument of variable
assumptions but rather
i will focus on how to get the sharp
bounds of the average treatment effect
so that is the
the difference is that the value of
those potential outcomes we flip the
status of the treatment x i want to say
that y index by xc the first coordinate
is the treatment we care about
we want to get this bound expressed as
uh the functionals of this observed
distribution p x y z okay
um
so in this case um
we may make uh
the following assumptions the first
assumption
is an exclusion restriction that
basically says on the individual level
encouragement would have no
effect means encouragement only has
effect through the actual vaccine that
you're taking
so that means on the individual level
the random variable y keeping the same x
while flipping z would be the same
and that means essentially this
potential outcome random variable y of
xc is only indexed by x and it's not a
function of z
okay
the other
assumption that would be plausible in
this case is the joint exogenoid that
basically says because the instrument z
is completely randomized uh you should
find plausible to be jointly independent
with the vector of the potential
outcomes of y and there are four of them
well under in the immediate level
exclusion i can write y of x so there
are only two actual potential outcomes
uh and the joint exogenoid can be
written as z independent of this vector
y of x zero y of x one
oh okay so this is the potential outcome
notation y of xd denotes the underlying
potential outcome
of whether you're accepted
have you received a particular treatment
x a particular encouragement z
so it's a counterfactual
variable
that is
that is the goal of our inference right
at least
so under these two assumptions the
individual level exclusion and the joint
exogenoid by joint i mean z independent
of this random vector
um
the bulky and pearl worked out the
following bounds on the average
treatment effect and they further prove
that they are sharp under these two
assumptions
so here is the bound on the average
treatment in fact and tau is average of
trim effect we care about and the both
lower and upper bound
is a
you know well the lower bound is
supremum over
four linear quantities of the observed
distribution eight observed distribution
and the upper bound is minimum over
eight linear quantities of the observed
distribution uh
you don't have to look too closely just
remember eight and eight okay
all right um but uh there could be
concerns about applying uh those bulky
parallel bounds for partial
identification because the assumptions
we previously have are actually cross
world
what that means
is that involves
stating something about the two
counterfactuals that you can not see
simultaneously even hypothetically
um
so that means more precisely if you
imagine a hypothetical study where both
the encouragement and the actual vaccine
status are randomized and this is the
forearm study both x and z are random x
and z are randomized and based on the
data from that hypothetical study you
wouldn't we wouldn't be able to
reject the hypothesis
of the
individual level exclusion and the joint
exogenoid
further
about this
joint exogeneity
this assumption may become less
plausible when z is not randomized which
is the case uh for many actions that we
use for for example econometrics for
example z being the same laws or
proximity to the college
you might just think you know this is
not randomized so
you might be a little bit
concerned when you postulate in this
cross-world assumption of joining
sergeant knight
i would want to say that
so
okay so is that clear that these are
cross-world unfalsifiable assumptions
because even in a hypothetical
randomized study if you look at a person
right you would only only see y of a
single x single z you wouldn't see the
other guy so that you would able to
actually compare
the two potential outcomes to see if
they are equal
and for the next one
there for each unit you only see one of
the y of xc's you wouldn't see the
others so you wouldn't have data to
reject the hypothesis of this joint
independence
okay i want to say that the walking
parabons can be derived under weakened
but still
cross-world assumptions
okay
so let's switch our assumptions uh to
some weaker assumptions
so we can replace
the individual level exclusion with the
population level exclusion
what that's what i call the marginal
stochastic exclusion
so instead of saying the two random
variables on the individual level are
the same i'm only saying
that for fixed x when i've flipped z
the individual of the the random
variable would have the same
distribution because we're dealing with
binary data the binary potential
outcomes so this is equivalent to say
the two have the same expectation
and this is assumption which can be
potentially falsified in an experiment
where we randomize both axis z because
you can look at the two arms for for a
particular x you can look at the two
arms for that x of different z and
compare
their actual mean and if you find that
means to be different then you should
hypothetically roll out this hypothesis
for exogenoity uh i'm going to replace
joining his argentinity where z
independent of four potential outcomes
by this marginal exogenoid is a
basically saying z
independent every one of the entry
of the joint of the random vector
and this is assumption where you can
also have a hope to falsify
in a hypothetical experiment because you
can look at
arm's data
arms y and c
um
and see if that's independent
of z
so those are uh the weaker more
plausible assumptions that have a chance
to be falsified by a hypothetical
experiment
now under these assumptions
manske and robins
derive the bound on the average
treatment in fact and
this is
a
bound where i have the maximum over four
numbers in the lower bound and the
minimum four numbers in the upper bound
so actually if you compare this
robin's masking belt so this is a
weaker
bound compared to the bulky pearl bound
you'll see actually
these
robin's masking bounds upper bound
a lower bound is only taking taking the
maximum over a subset of those numbers
and the upper bound is only taking the
minimum over the subset of numbers and
hence
um
robin's masking bound would be
a weaker bound
than the previous bulky parabounce
um so these
masking and robins bound are also called
the natural bounds
uh so the vocabulary bounds are strictly
sharper than the robin's message bounds
so the question of this talk is to see
whether we can fill this gap or if this
got fundamental in some sense
okay uh so for the rest of the talk uh
i'm going to
use counter fracture of s
as index by z
um
you know uh
just to think x is actually
uh an effect of z
and this is uh this is just to you know
align with some of the literature and
this is not essential for derivation
so previously we have this graph now if
i imagine
z could have effect on x so i'm going to
use this graph where i allow the latent
confounding between z and x but this
confounder should be independent of the
co-founder that compounds x and y
okay
so i'm going to try to formulate
the previous weaker hypothesis that is
the marginal uh
the the marginal exclusion uh the
stochastic exclusion and the marginal
exogenoidity in terms of the latent
variables so what i'm going to do is to
use this single world intervention graph
swig
introduced by thomas and jamie
so i'm going to look at this graph and
i'm going to draw the single world
intervention graph
so what that means is
z and x are variables that can be
intervened so i'm going to intervene at
z
and that z splits into two parts the
random part z and this fixed part
literacy and i'm going to
index the the counter factuals of x y by
the value of the litter z and then i'm
going to yes
just as a clarifying issue so
this is a single world intervention
graph right but there is a missing edge
from
from c to
y here and earlier said that the fact
that that is missing corresponds to a
multi-world statement i just wanted to
flag that it's an interesting thing
i don't think there's a problem that's
just a feature of switch that's a little
factory
oh yeah
so i'm not friends
follow me so so you were talking about
exclusion restrictions right so basic
edge this way corresponds to exclusive
restrictions excluding restriction
individual level the world statements as
you said a few slides ago right right i
think i just think that's interesting to
point out basically right as you'll see
so that that actually means the
exclusion restriction and uh of the
stochastic marginal method
yeah yeah you can do this yeah yeah the
linen variable yes this is precisely
what it says it's an unbearable
exclusion of the reformulation of that
of the risks the exclusion
okay so
now you can read this graph um
that two assumptions would replace
our two previous assumptions
so one uh the fact that as
hidden said this there is no edge from z
to y
this missing edge from this fixed lead
to this confection y
signifies the linear variable stochastic
exclusion
what that means is that this y of x c
essentially
is only indexed by x on the population
level
um
furthermore
well graphically you will read this as z
you know
not connected to y of x c given u
so this is the statement that the
counter factuals with different z's
conditional u they have the same
distribution
and because we're dealing with binary
data again this is equivalent to taking
this conditional expectation of the
counter factor y giving you are the same
um
so
this is the latent variable formulation
of stochastic exclusion and we can
easily see that this implies the
previous stochastic exclusion by
integrating out u
right
the conditional mean the same implies
the marginal means are the same
um
the second assumption uh that you can
also read off from this wig
is the latent variable marginal
exogenoidity in this case that is the
instrument z being marginally
independent of u
and
this counterfactual y
given u is separated from both the
instrument z and the counterfactual xc
and
these two uh latent variables what i
call the landmark variable marginality
would imply the previous marginal
exogenoidity again by integrating out u
or you can read up from the graph indeed
z marginally is independent of this kind
of actual
y of x c
so basically i'm going to replace the
the previous two
uh assumptions by these latent variable
some versions of the assumptions and
these linear variable version
assumptions if you integrate u that just
recovered the previous stochastic
exclusion and the margins argument
now the the main claim of this talk is
to say that actually if you switch to
those latent variable formulation of the
stochastic exclusion and marginal
nutritionality you can obtain the
stronger bulky pearl bounds and they are
actually sharp are those in variable
formulations
okay so first let's see that it's
relatively easy to see
uh if the berkey poor bounds hold on
these assumptions they must be sharp
well how do how do you say how do you
see that
basically uh we can go back to the
strongest assumption of the individual
level exclusion and and join
exogenoidity in that model
i can
instantiate this model by choosing a
particular u i basically i can choose u
to be the set of counterfactual y z
therefore them i choose u
to be the vector of those kind of
factuals then
the linen variable stochastic exclusion
reduces to individual level exclusion
and the linear variable marginal
exogenoid reduces to the joining surgeon
height
because we know
the berkeley pearl bounds can be
achieved by some distribution under
these two strong assumptions then it
follows that just by choosing u in a
particular way
if the blocking power bounds hold then
they must be sharp and because they can
be achieved by choosing such you
exactly
okay in fact
we have basically seen that in terms of
models and this is a relation basically
the latent variable formulation is
sandwiched between the stronger
hypothesis a stronger the set of
stronger assumptions and the set of
weaker assumptions
okay just remind you uh these are
different assumptions and the latent
variable formulation are supposed to be
in the middleway uh between the stronger
individual unfalsifiable assumptions and
the weaker falsifiable assumptions
it's nothing just just involve
conditioning on this latent variable u
there exists such a u and condition on
that such you and you have this
reformulation of stochastic exclusion
and the marginalization
now i'm going to show
then how
we can derive the bulky probe bounds
under those linen variable formulations
of the assumptions
so basically we have already seen that
if you marginalize out the linear
variable u from this linear variable
formulations you get nothing but the
previous stochastic exclusion and
marginal exhaustionality and then we
know under those case the tightest
bounce we can get is uh the mesquite
robin span
right so there must be something that we
haven't fully exploited in terms of the
linear variable hypothesis and that is
that is precisely
where we have to look at this graph
okay so if we look at this graph this is
the swig
and
basically we have to move the limbs of
this graph slightly in this way
so i'm just doing nothing other than
just moving some of the parts in a more
apparent way
then
this
resembles
this famous
graph pertaining to the chsh inequality
where
alice and bob share a common random
source and they independently
get their settings and do their
measurements and the chsh inequality
categorizes uh this correlation between
alice's
measurements and bob's measurements so
the correspondence would be
here this linear confounding between x
and y would replace the random source
and this little x and little z will
replace the the kind of the exogenous
alice's head setting and above setting
and this x of z and y of xd these two
kind of factuals would replace alice's
outcome and bob's outcome
so this is nothing but just a
realization that the graph contains a
subgraph basically that should encode
this chs-h inequality
right
so as i said um the csus inequality is
usually uh or commonly is postulated on
in terms of correlations so you have
this
so a and a prime
corresponds to
alice's measurements when a
so alice's has two type of settings so a
and a prime corresponds to alice's
measurements when a alice chooses one
setting versus the other and the same
for b and b prime and this is the
correlations that basically you know has
three plus and one minus
um
that's the structure
okay so for our purpose so basically the
security source must be the csgs
inequality and
somehow we have to use uh this
correlation encoded by csgsh
for that purpose um i'm going to write
the chsh inequality slightly differently
to suit our purpose
so here is a claim so under the linen
variable hypotheses
we have the following bells such as edge
inequalities
so if you look at this so this is
basically
um so there are four terms
a linear combination of four terms and
they have a lower bound zero and upper
bound one
and uncannily they have three pluses and
one minus
okay so that's like the csh sh structure
and each of the term is actually a
conditional distribution of x and a y of
x c but i would advise you to think
about this x is as the counter factor x
by consistency right so this when z is
equal to little z you can replace this
mentally replaces x by x and little z so
that basically uh this is a
the counter factual the joint
distribution of the counter factuals for
the arm where big z equal to little z
and these the first two terms about the
counterfactual conditional distribution
within
the z and the next two terms about the
counterfactual destroying distribution
with the other z's
so this basically inequality that's
relating the two different branches
where z take the opposite values
this is a relation about the kind of the
conditional distribution of the counter
factuals condition on z but relating to
different values of z
okay um
so how do we get this uh basically
we can think about this constraint
uh as the marginalization of this these
constraints i'm doing nothing other than
just
inserting u two into each of the
conditionals
okay so if we can prove this then by
just integrating down u
with respect to any marginal
distribution of u we actually recover uh
the chs in essential inequality
and okay so let's just look at
uh
this sum of uh this combination of four
terms for example let's just take out
the first term
so this concerns x and y's
counterfactual distribution given z
given this little confounder u between x
and y
now
uh by consistency i can replace this x
by x of z of that particular z we
conditioned on
this the first step just follows by
consistency
and the second step where we have to use
our hypothesis
um so i'm going to use the
linen variable exogenoity so basically
condition on z and u
uh this s counter factual and a y
counter fraction would be conditionally
independent so i would have x given x z
and u
and the other term would be y given z
and u
but
uh
by
but
y given u is further independent of z so
i can replace the second one by y giving
you
okay so following this logic i can
basically write each of the term as a
product the two terms of this type
and
and funnily enough uh what actually
comes to bound
uh these sum of four products is
actually a really basic equal
equality
so if you give so you can basically
identify these terms as a b u v and
these are probabilities so they have to
be between zero and one
and
for any four numbers between zero one
actually this is a kind of a trivial
bound i want to say trivial but this is
quite quite elementary bound
and this is about that you can realize
just by looking at the graph of a
hyperbolic parabola
that
zero is a saddle point they go down in
one direction they go everything out the
other direction just by using just by
using the graph of a hyperbolic parabola
you can basically prove
uh a bound on these
combinations of four products and
further by integrating how you would get
the chs inequality as stated here
okay
so finally
i'm just going to show that if we use
those chassis inequalities we can indeed
derive the bulky parallel bounds because
previously we said if walking pro
bounces are true they must be sharp then
this would prove that the work employer
bounce hold under those variable
formulations and they are indeed shot
okay so i i'm
less technically adequate than sml in
dealing with algebra so i think what i'm
going to do is doing it quite in a quite
mechanistic way by using linear programs
so i'm going to
just set up a linear program
so one set of variables i i want to put
in my inner program
is these conditional distributions of
the counter fraction of x c and y of x c
so i can set up these things
these are just conditional probability
tables i can introduce the entries of
those variables as variable as
programming variables
and then i'm going to
encode our counterfactual assumptions so
just think about this guy this polytope
at the set of counterfactual
distributions under our assumptions
so obviously because there are
probability tables they have to be
non-negative sum to one so these are
simplest constraints i can put in there
and
the uh integrated variable assumptions
when i integrate out u they just become
the stochastic exclusion the marginal
suggestion and i can put them i can
encode them as constraints with respect
to those variables and those are just
you know affine constraints of those
variables and finally i will put the
previous chs inequality concerning those
variables also
so in the second step i'm going to
introduce another conditional property
table encoding the observed distribution
so this is just you know x and y being
binary conditional z beam binary
i introduce those as programming
variables and those are related to the
previous encoded contractual variables
through consistency so consistency is
also
so given you know counterfactual ones
you can you can construct the
distribution of the observed one this is
nothing but consistency and consistency
is also an affine constraint between
these conditional property tables and
these observed conditional property
tables
and finally
because i care about the uh the average
treatment in fact although that seems
principle works for any
uh
counterfactual functional that you could
care about
i'm going to introduce a variable
directly encodes the average treatment
in fact and this is a deterministic
function that you can compute from the
counterfactual conditional property
tables
and
then i basically have defined a
degenerate complex polytope over those
conditional property tables and this uh
average trimming effect
and finally
i'm just going to use you know
algebra
to ask a computer to do free masking
elimination
that basically
only retains coordinates of the observed
distribution conditional property tables
and
this average treatment effect
i'm going to do a uh projection of the
complex polytope onto those observed
coordinates and the functional i care
about
so if you do this calculation we get a
polytope with two
supporting hyperplanes
and 28 half spaces and among the 28 half
spaces
there are exactly 16 half spaces
that has a non-zero coefficient that
involves this every trim in fact and if
you look at this table and and
scrutinize it
you realize these are exactly uh the
breaking power balance because i have
the maximum over eight
linear functions in the lower bound and
a minimum over eight liter functions in
the upper bound so these 16 make up
exactly the four key problems
and to verify my claim that the chs-h is
exactly the the gap feels exactly the
gap between the 4k pearl and the
robismanski i can delete those chs
session quantities just delete them and
re-run this analysis and you will find
that these uh this table shrinks to half
and those exactly becomes the robin's
man's keyboard
so this shows seriously inequalities is
exactly um a bridge is exactly like that
so a little bit
i guess i'm running a bit early but
here are the
[Music]
summaries the situation inequality fails
it's got
and i want to mention that this is
perhaps not the
first result that shows that proves the
blockchain pro bounds
using latin variable
phil david has a previous paper that he
considers a particular linear variable
formulation that avoids using
counterfactuals where he shows the bulky
per bounce hold and they're tight so
but i guess
this is more explicit in showing the
role of cssh in this gap between the
weaker iv bounds and the stronger ed
events
i think more generally
this kind of points to the message that
obtaining tight partition
identification bounds perhaps
need not rely on falsifiable or
crossword assumptions
and i would say i would say perhaps
looking at the population levels week
could be a good starting point in
reading off some of the single world
natural assumptions when you try to work
out start working on project
identification
and another point
which is the takeaway message is that to
obtain really sharp bounds
uh we have to
think about the linear variable
formulation
and to truly understand what the
inequality constraints are there in
another variable formulation again i
think this is where uh you want to use a
graph
that
encodes both observed and 100
differential variables and swig can be
useful here so in in our case we consult
a swig and we find this particular
motive that
encodes the chs inequality that allows
us to fill this gap more generally i
think this could be a strategy um to
think about swig when deriving those
parts identification bounds
and finally
linear or convex more generally convex
programming is a useful tool if you're
not
extremely dexterous with algebraic
manipulations
i want to say to add to the last point
that this programming can be useful can
be even extended for conducting
statistical inference
so for example
let's say i want to actually
do statistical inference uh uh on the
average treatment effect or any kind of
factual functional that i care about
using data okay
so
so this graph so this
blue this green dot here is the actual
mle of the data consider everything
being discrete
and this convex programming actually
provides a strategy of doing often
difficult inference on
are
those
every treatment fast given data and the
idea is
that you can think about data
you can think about constructing a
confidence region
for your observed distribution based on
the data
and this gives you this intersection
between the
observed model and
the
little ellipses around the observed mle
and then you can map those back
to the counter factual world and then
read off the lower and upper bound for a
particular
counter factual functional and that if
the confidence region has good coverage
property that just translates to the
probability coverage property
of the
of the counterfactual function
so the idea is
again represent the counterfactual
distribution observed distribution as
probability tables
and encode the counterfactual
constraints as
linear constraints on the conditional
property table
and link them
through consistency
and finally the added step is to
relate the observed distribution to the
data through some you know convex
confidence region around
the estimate of the data
and finally you just
query the minimum and maximum in this
convex optimization problem
and it would be desirable to use a
confidence region that is based on a
convex function of the observed
distribution
and one
choice could be using a annuity a new
development of the kl divergence that
delivers the final sample guarantee
um
okay i guess that's all for my talk
thanks for attending
that's a really interesting talk um so
presumably you could have um not put the
chsh in directly but just
had a kind of latent variable
formulation for
the swig
so because you get the chsh
using linear programming as well
yes you just have to have types for
counterfactuals
um
but are you
proposing encoding the latest no just
i'm just trying to understand
whether that's correct right so is it
just the case that i could not have the
chsh in the program
and just say
okay i know that um
you know the latent variable u come with
atlas generality just contain
x of z
and then
plug those constraints in so they're all
equalities
and then you get the chs as well
that's interesting i'm not
not sure actually
i haven't haven't tried it
yeah so could you just go back to slide
11 because it's just one thing
so i think part of the if i'm
understanding a logic here that the idea
is that you have
we have these
there's a difference between the latent
variable assumptions and the other ones
that are here in the sense that the
latent variable is postulating the
existence of this u
and so for example um so
these bounds were originally derived
using potential outcomes and then there
was the challenge well was it really
necessary to have potential outcomes or
counterfactuals in order to derive these
bands and so phil david then did derive
the bounds but he derived the bounds
using it in a model where he assumed the
existence of a you
but given that the original reason for
trying to get rid of the potential
outcomes was sort of a philosophical
concern that
we're not sure that these potential
outcomes are well defined
it could be seen as question begging to
then invoke the existence of a you
because especially if you read the proof
in detail the you that he that the proof
retains the bounds by considering
extreme or use and those u's are very
close similar to potential outcomes so
basically the you take states that make
x of z and y of x the deterministic
functions of the other variables so that
left open the gap here which was
essentially to say if we want can we get
uh can we get to
derive the bulky pearl bounds without
making assumptions about unobservables
um okay so that's that's sort of i think
partly so it was a it was a sort of
theoretical question about what was it
was there a way to state if i don't talk
about you is there a way to state what
are the additional assumptions that are
necessary
explicitly
but yeah that's that's the point but
basically yes i mean that that's the
point of the talk it's a different thing
to
assume you is just telling you
then say what to do
why is that different i mean the the
issue is to show that that uh
that these assumptions the assumptions
that are there the marginal assumptions
class chsh got the bulky problems
there's one other point i wanted to make
a sort of comment on this which is
the
when you're saying random assignment is
implausible i think you mean in the
context of an observational stuff
because i mean there are circumstances
you can make random assignments here
hold by design yes in which case it's
not required
at least not in non quantum context
i think i'm asking sort of along the
same lines
when
you invoke sort of a swig um and you're
you're driving uh
[Music]
conference without invoking cross-world
assumptions of everything sort of single
world assumptions right to my mind as a
physicist you're doing something that
doesn't involve looking at
uh both
uh counterfactuals simultaneously such
as asking what would y be at the same
time for both values of x and that's
sort of like we're limiting ourselves to
quantum safe or or
the kind of logic that works in
generalization theories and so you can
go to the bell graph and say that the
counter factuals and the instrumental
variable can be related to quantities in
the background but the only knowledge
you could then use on the on the graph
to pull back are the sort of same uh
safe
uh assumptions which do not involve
crossroad counterfactuals and chsh very
much is not of that flavor
so um the idea of like oh you get strong
bounds if you make these sort of natural
assumptions the manskey robins that
sounds fine because that's what you
would get if you assumed uh things that
you hold for all physical theories and
not involving crossfire gun variables
and if you
make the assumption that crossword 10
factors exist you get stronger about
your body for all and of course if you
use chs8 you get the stronger ones
because seep stage is entirely based on
the existence of crossword kind of
factors that's like the premise behind
it so it's just
yeah that's exactly the point i feel
like yeah
i mean yeah you need you basically need
the some type of cross-world assumption
but in this case that's induced by the
existence very existence of this linear
variable you
so
i guess that's
the
source because you just look at the
formulations itself it doesn't seem to
involve cross-world statements but
once you
uncover this underlying station
essentially it's actually it is a
statement involved different
you know
crossword carnations
and you have to use this to
to arrive stronger
thank you and but i think to follow to
follow up my point is when you condition
on this unobservable u that is not
really defined this u could also contain
y zero
so in some sense you you are making you
may
make some cause for the assumption right
yes it may or may not i just
i remain agnostic about the nature of
youth but really because you are making
you are
you are agnostic about that that's why i
think that maybe the situation that is
giving you this bound is a situation
where the u is exactly related to y zero
and then you are making some crossword
assumption between y one and y zero
that makes sense what i'm saying so
you're saying that at a point where the
bound is achieved is where the u is
instantiated by y y zero yes this is a
function of like y one and y zero so so
yes so that's why i think i want to get
more sense about what are the algebraic
situation that's going to give you the
html points
because those html points could be
exactly the situation where u is a
deterministic function of y 1 and y 0
that while you are getting this say ch
estimation
but this is my adjustment
i don't know it's possible uh for
example if you look at the
you know for example working profiles
can be derived when you instantiate u to
be the set of four
uh the vector of counterfactuals but
is that the only case i i don't know
let's just add a quick comment here i
mean basically part of the language was
supposing i'm someone interested in the
bulky power bands
but i don't think in terms of use
and the only quantities i've got are x
of z and y of x e
and then i'm willing to make those those
weak assumptions and then i want to
understand what extra would i have to
make in order to get to the bulky bell
bands
and i understand that you know this is
probably not surprising to people in
here that chsh inequalities are
you know
intimately tied to the idea of their
existing slate variable but for example
if you read pearl's work then
he talks about testing the iv
inequalities as being like the bell
inequalities so it's about the
falsification test and the instrumental
inequality so it wasn't totally obvious
to us at least when we started out maybe
of maybe sort of similar to people
think about belt's inequality for longer
it wasn't obvious to us that that was
the missing piece and that was all that
was needed that was the only piece that
was needed
that had to be added so it's not that
we're advocating assuming that chs
inequalities just that we wanted to
understand
in a language where you don't talk about
you you only talk about y of x c and x
of z what is the extra piece that you
need to get from these very weak
assumptions
to the bulky pearl bounds and that
that's the question we're out to answer
sir